Your personality is what makes you uniquely and consistently you. Personality
is defined as an individual's pattern of thinking, feeling and behaving. Now,
let's take this hypothetical situation. What if I just met Rosio and I see her
acting in an unfriendly way? Am I likely to conclude that she's an unfriendly
person? Well, I might. But that might not be correct. Because I've only seen
her acting this way in that one situation. I haven't seen her under many
circumstances over a long period of time, and those are two things that we need
if we're going to make a conclusion about someone's personality. We just know
something about the mood she was in, or how she was behaving that day.
Everybody acts differently sometimes. The most introverted person can light up
when they're around their friends. The kindest person can sometimes be angry or
even hostile. But personality is how we behave most of the time.